hi everyone my name is Kathleen O'Toole
and the assistant provost for k-12
education here at Hillsdale College and
I'm here to talk to you about how
Hillsdale College can help you during
this very surprising and strange time
that we suddenly find ourselves in like
you we had a lot of plans for the rest
of the semester
which have now been completely derailed
we had planned to visit our affiliated
schools in Texas and Idaho we had
planned to put on a conference for board
members and all of a sudden we find
ourselves down here in the studio
putting together training for teachers
students and parents in other words
we're still here for you but the means
by which we're doing that are suddenly
different what you're gonna see on this
website is a whole bunch of resources
that we hope will be helpful to you
while you're figuring out how to do
education from home there are a few
classical principles that are always at
work whether a parent or a teacher is
doing the teaching and the purpose of
these videos is to teach you what those
are classical education at its root is
common sense education I don't know
about you but I've seen a lot of
articles on the internet recently from
frustrated moms who think that the work
of teachers is mysterious and
complicated and only possible because
they're experts and what we hope this
website will show you is that you the
parent or the guardian or the aunt or
the uncle or the grandmother or the
grandfather of these children you have
already within you the things that you
need to help your children continue to
make progress at home you have been
doing this your whole life since the
early earliest days of your child's life
you are teaching that child you were you
were there when they learned to talk you
were there when they learn to walk you
were there from the very very beginning
stages of their education and the
principles of that are not so different
from the principles of the education
that your children are receiving in
school in other words you can do this
and we're here to help
you